This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和增强恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《迎难而上》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有资质的专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode.
为了我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴有你们在这里。欢迎收看又一期节目。
Thank you for tuning in. Today, we're going to talk about consistency. A big question I get is how to build consistency in our 20s. I think during this decade, We all have a lot of really huge visions and ambitions and ideas about our life. It's also the time when we are having to achieve certain goals and milestones such as graduating uni or pursuing our career or being entrepreneurial and all of that comes with a level of consistency that is important for our success.
感谢收听。今天，我们将讨论坚持。我经常被问到的一个大问题是如何在我们二十多岁时培养坚持的习惯。我认为在这个十年里，我们所有人对自己的生活都有很多非常宏大的愿景、雄心和想法。这也是我们必须实现某些目标和里程碑的时期，例如大学毕业、追求职业发展或创业，所有这些都需要一定程度的坚持，这对我们的成功至关重要。
But the truth is that none of our visions, none of our ideas. ideas about our life are going to come true if we are not consistent and disciplined. We often engage in a lot of fantasy thinking, myself included, but a lot of us then struggle with the follow-through. We struggle with procrastination. We struggle with motivation. It's only natural to feel distracted or to lack motivation. However, when motivation fails, and habits will sustain us. They will step in and keep us on track. They're our safety net if we take the time to build them and work on creating sustainable
但事实是，如果我们不够坚持、不够自律，我们的任何愿景、任何关于生活的想法都不会实现。我们经常进行大量的幻想思考，包括我在内，但我们中的很多人随后又在执行力上苦苦挣扎。我们在拖延中挣扎。我们在动力上挣扎。感到分心或缺乏动力是再自然不过的事情了。然而，当动力不足时，习惯将支撑我们。它们会介入并让我们保持正轨。如果我们花时间去建立并努力朝着我们的目标创造可持续的习惯，它们就是我们的安全网。
habits towards our goals. There is a quote I repeat all the time that relates to this, which is that the secret to success is consistency. And that really applies to anything. It applies to our career. It applies to academia and studying. It applies to our side hustles, but also to things like our relationships and personal goals around things like fitness or our ambitions in really any area. So today, we're going to dive into the psychology behind motivation and staying consistent.
我经常重复一句与此相关的话，那就是成功的秘诀在于坚持。这确实适用于任何事情。它适用于我们的职业生涯。它适用于学术和学习。它适用于我们的副业，但也适用于诸如人际关系、围绕健身等个人目标，或者我们在真正任何领域的雄心。所以今天，我们将深入探讨动力背后的心理学以及如何保持坚持。
What is the secret ingredient and the science behind consistency? How can we build long-term habits? Why do we sometimes struggle with motivation and procrastination or worst of all, all or nothing thinking, especially in our 20s? And I guess finally, how can we use consistency and how can we harness consistency to prevent burnout and stay focused whilst still enjoying our lives? We have a lot of goals, right? A lot of us want to achieve big things or even small things.
坚持背后的秘密成分和科学是什么？我们如何建立长期的习惯？为什么有时我们会与动力和拖延症作斗争，或者最糟糕的是，陷入非黑即白的思维，特别是在我们二十多岁的时候？我想最后，我们如何利用坚持，如何利用坚持来防止精疲力竭并保持专注，同时依然享受生活？我们有很多目标，对吧？我们很多人都想成就大事，甚至小事。
Every one of us, I think even as humans, we all have something that we want to do to make our lives better. But sometimes that can consume us. And particularly in our 20s, we are meant to have fun. This is a decade that we are meant to enjoy and we want to be balanced. So how can we utilize the psychological concepts behind consistency to ensure our cups are full, whilst we are still striving towards our goals. This is the episode to get motivated. This is the episode to sustain us,
我们每个人，我想甚至作为人类，我们都有想要去做的事情，以让我们的生活变得更好。但有时这会消耗我们。特别是在我们二十多岁的时候，我们注定是要享受乐趣的。这是我们注定要享受的十年，我们希望生活是平衡的。那么，我们如何利用坚持背后的心理学概念来确保我们的心灵得到充实，同时仍然朝着我们的目标努力呢。这就是激发动力的那一集。这就是支撑我们的一集，
to build those habits, to build our consistency. So if there's something, a goal you have in mind, and you're ready to achieve it, you're ready to get there. Let's get into how we can do that and how we can stay consistent.
去建立那些习惯，培养我们的坚持。所以，如果你心中有一个目标，并且准备好实现它，准备好达成目标。让我们来探讨如何做到这一点以及如何保持坚持。
As always, let's start with the basics. Let's start at the very beginning with the building blocks. So what exactly is consistency? So consistency as it relates to human behavior refers to behaving in the same dependable way. It's an adjective that we can use to describe someone. We can call someone consistent. But it's also a verb because consistency requires action. And it can be really hard to master because I think our world has become full of distractions. And sometimes our goals, as well can be really ambiguous and finding a path forward is quite hard. I think about that in terms of
像往常一样，让我们从基础开始。让我们从最初的构建块开始。那么，到底什么是坚持呢？因此，与人类行为相关的坚持，是指以同样可靠的方式行事。这是一个我们可以用来形容某人的形容词。我们可以称某人为坚持不懈的人。但它也是一个动词，因为坚持需要行动。要掌握它真的很难，因为我认为我们的世界已经充满了干扰。有时我们的目标也可能非常含糊，找到前进的道路相当困难。我想到了我在
my own experience with this show. You know, when I first started it, I didn't really have the biggest ambitions for it. It was just kind of something that I found fun. But the further I got into it, the further I fell in love with it, suddenly it became more than just a passion and it became an ambition. And I became a lot more goal directed. But it was hard to kind of, kind of, of understand how I could be consistent in it and how I could sustain this behavior and sustain my passion and my motivation for it. And what I found was that breaking things down and creating sustainable habits was the easiest way to still have fun doing it, but also kind of get shit done. If you want anything in life, the truth is that you do have to be consistent. You have
自己制作这个节目的经历。你知道，当我刚开始做的时候，我对它并没有什么太大的野心。它只是我发现的一件有趣的事情。但随着我深入其中，我越来越爱上它，突然间它不再仅仅是一种热情，而变成了一种雄心。我变得更有目标导向了。但很难去理解我该如何在其中保持坚持，以及如何维持这种行为并维持我对它的热情和动力。我发现，将事情拆解并创造可持续的习惯，是既能一边享受乐趣又能把事情做好的最简单方法。如果你想要生活中的任何东西，事实是你必须保持坚持。你必须
to be aligned to your purpose in a manner that is steadfast and focused. That doesn't mean having every hour of your day planned out or needing to be robotic. Absolutely not. I think it's more about incremental daily behaviors from which we can achieve our goals. Everyone listening to this has a goal in mind. I want you to sit back and reflect on what that is. We all have something we're striving towards. It's very natural and only natural, I think, as humans to want to be better.
以坚定和专注的方式与你的目标保持一致。这并不意味着把一天中的每个小时都规划好，或者需要像机器人一样。绝对不是。我认为这更多的是关于我们可以从中实现目标的循序渐进的日常行为。听这个节目的每个人心中都有一个目标。我希望你坐下来反思一下那是什么。我们所有人都有一个为之奋斗的目标。作为人类，想要变得更好是非常自然且理所当然的事情。
And that doesn't have to be something large and intense like being a millionaire or owning a Lamborghini or becoming president. It can be something as simple as drinking more water or doing your dishes every day. Goals are so subjective, but I think the formula to achieving them is very much the same. From a psychological perspective, struggling with consistency is a universal experience. So much can get in our way and can jeopardize our goals. There are things like distractions, I think, especially our phones, captivate so much more of our attention these days.
这不一定非得是像成为百万富翁、拥有一辆兰博基尼或当上总统那样宏大而激烈的事情。它可以是一些简单的事情，比如多喝水或者每天洗碗。目标是非常主观的，但我认为实现它们的公式在很大程度上是相同的。从心理学的角度来看，与坚持作斗争是一种普遍的体验。很多事情都会阻碍我们并危及我们的目标。有些事情比如干扰，我认为尤其是我们的手机，这些天吸引了我们更多的注意力。
There is procrastination, which we know is linked with perfectionism and an inability to start a task or concern about an outcome that means we can't even begin. and then there's also a lack of motivation. Motivation is very fickle. And there's a lot of science that explains why that is the case. Our brains have limited time, limited and limited resources essentially at the end of the day. When you think about your brain and your mind,
还有拖延症，我们知道这与完美主义有关，由于无法开始一项任务或对结果的担忧，导致我们甚至无法开始。然后还有缺乏动力。动力是非常善变的。有很多科学可以解释为什么会这样。归根结底，我们的大脑有着有限的时间、有限的资源。当你想到你的大脑和思维时，
it really can only hold so much information. And when we are incredibly focused on a goal, that is going to take up a lot more brains. space than the rest of the things that we have going on in our lives. However, those things are still important. So I think about this in terms of studying for your final exams. That is a massive goal for a lot of us that we want to do well academically. And when we're focused on that, that takes up like 50% of our brain capacity, spending time at the library, staying up to date with coursework, going through the motions. But that motivation can be hard to sustain,
它实际上只能容纳这么多的信息。当我们极度专注于一个目标时，它会占用比我们生活中正在进行的其余事情多得多的脑力空间。然而，这些事情依然很重要。所以我想到了期末考试复习。对于我们许多人来说，在学术上取得好成绩是一个巨大的目标。当我们专注于这一点时，它会占用我们大约50%的脑力，花时间在图书馆，跟上课程作业，按部就班地进行。但这种动力很难维持，
because other things are going to come up and take up more space. Say a member of your family gets sick or you need to work. You're struggling financially. That is going to come in and carve out the mental space that we had devoted to our goal so that we can repurpose it and devote it to the other things that are important to us. So that is why I think motivation can sometimes be very hard to get a handle on. and in those situations in which you have a lot going on in which there are so many things demanding your attention such that your motivation can fail you.
因为其他事情会接踵而至并占据更多空间。比如你的某个家庭成员生病了，或者你需要工作。你面临着经济困难。这将会介入并侵蚀我们原本用于目标的心理空间，以便我们能够将其重新挪用并投入到对我们重要的其他事情上去。这就是为什么我认为动力有时很难掌控的原因。在那些你有很多事情要处理、有那么多事情需要你关注以至于动力可能会让你失望的情况下，
Consistency and positive habits are what's going to sustain you. And I think a lot of us are looking for a cheat sheet or a shortcut to our ambitions, but the secret ingredient is actually not that secret. It's hard work and it's consistency. and when we employ certain habits and methods, that hard work doesn't need to feel so burdensome. So I want to focus on five key pieces of advice around building consistency that I use on an almost daily basis. And whatever goal you have in mind, I promise one, if not all of these things, is going to
坚持和积极的习惯将是支撑你的东西。我想我们很多人都在寻找通往雄心的作弊指南或捷径，但秘诀其实并不那么神秘。那就是努力工作和坚持不懈。当我们采用某些习惯和方法时，这种努力工作就不必感觉那么沉重了。所以我想重点介绍关于培养坚持的五个关键建议，我几乎每天都在使用它们。无论你心里有什么目标，我保证这些建议中总有一条（如果不是全部的话）会
help you. The first one is micro habits. micro habits are so valuable in everyone's life. Essentially what they are, and as the name suggests, they are small, daily things that are almost negligible that build to bigger, deeper, sustained, life-changing habits. The term micro, meaning small,
对你有所帮助。第一个是微习惯。微习惯在每个人的生活中都非常有价值。从本质上讲，顾名思义，它们是微小的、日常的、几乎可以忽略不计的事情，却能累积成更大、更深、持续的、改变生活的习惯。微这个词，意思是小，
is the crucial component of this idea. And essentially, the idea goes that if you start small, and build up to those bigger, larger goals, you are going to ensure long-term success, you are going to retain those behaviours, but you're also going to prevent burnout. And they're really easy to integrate. So a micro habit around getting healthier, around treating your body better, might be something like, I want to have a glass of water the moment that I wake up in the morning because I'm worried about my hydration. Or at least once a day I want to eat a piece of fruit. Or I just want to walk to the train station every morning rather than getting an Uber. Or I want to walk
是这个概念中至关重要的组成部分。本质上，这个想法是，如果你从小处着手，并逐步朝着那些更大、更宏伟的目标迈进，你将确保长期的成功，你将保持这些行为，同时你也将防止精疲力竭。而且它们真的很容易融入生活。因此，关于变得更健康、更好地对待身体的微习惯，可能是这样的：我想在早晨醒来的那一刻就喝一杯水，因为我担心我的水分补充。或者至少一天吃一次水果。或者我只想每天早晨步行去火车站，而不是叫网约车。或者我想步行
to work rather than getting the train. These habits are things that are not going to interrupt our life to the point that they cause us discomfort or to the point where they force us to change things rapidly. I think when we go after a goal, our tendency is to start really big. Say, for example, you want to run a marathon. Often, what we do is we go out and we try and run as fast and as hard and as long as we possibly can. We start off day one with like a 10K and then the next day we are exhausted and we're so tired and we give up because it's painful. But the idea behind me, micro habits is that you can get to that goal. Perhaps it's going to take you longer than if you went all out, but it will be more sustainable if you slowly build up based on these daily
去上班，而不是坐火车。这些习惯不会打扰我们的生活到引起我们不适的程度，也不会迫使我们迅速改变现状。我认为当我们追求一个目标时，我们的倾向往往是开局就搞得很大。比方说，你想跑马拉松。通常情况下，我们会做的是出去尝试尽可能快、尽可能拼、尽可能久地跑步。我们在第一天就开始跑大约10公里，然后第二天我们精疲力竭，累得要死，然后因为太痛苦而放弃了。但微习惯背后的理念是，你可以实现那个目标。也许这会比你全力以赴花费更长的时间，但如果你根据这些日常的
micro behaviours and actions that you can take. The next tip and the next kind of piece of advice I have to give is around short term versus long term goals. You need a mix of both. Like I said before, when we set out to achieve something, we often only ever think about the end goal or the finish line. And that can be incredibly dangerous. I'm sure you've heard this before, but all good things in life should be approached as a marathon, not a sprint, because life is not all about the huge successes, the massive celebrations and the huge rushes of dopamine that they bring us. And if we solely rely on reaching our big goals and our massive ambitions as our source of motivation, not only are we going to lose that consistency, not only are we going to lose motivation,
微小行为和你可以采取的行动慢慢积累，它会更具可持续性。我给出的下一个建议和技巧是关于短期目标与长期目标。你需要两者兼顾。就像我之前说的，当我们着手实现某个目标时，我们往往只考虑最终目标或终点线。这可能会极其危险。我相信你以前听过这个说法，生活中的所有美好事物都应该像马拉松一样去对待，而不是短跑，因为生活并不全都是巨大的成功、盛大的庆祝活动以及它们带来的大量多巴胺冲击。如果我们仅仅依靠达成大目标和宏大雄心作为动力的来源，我们不仅会失去这种坚持，不仅会失去动力，
but we'll probably be seriously disappointed. So the secret to building consistency in this domain is to utilize the power of incremental short-term goals, delayed gratification, and delayed reinforcement. We are used to receiving instant gratification from a lot of things in our life. And when I talk about instant gratification, what I mean is a very immediate dopamine hit. The example I give is social media. When you turn on your phone, you can immediately go on to Instagram and go on to TikTok and you will receive pleasant feelings from that. It will give you dopamine because it is making you, it is entertaining you essentially and it's giving you something to look at and it's fun and it's enjoyable and so you get your fix almost immediately.
而且可能会严重失望。因此，在这个领域建立坚持的秘诀在于利用循序渐进的短期目标、延迟满足和延迟强化。我们习惯了从生活中的很多事情中获得即时满足。当我谈论即时满足时，我的意思是极其即时的多巴胺冲击。我给出的例子是社交媒体。当你打开手机，你可以立即刷Instagram和TikTok，你会从中获得愉悦感。它会给你带来多巴胺，因为它正在让你感到快乐，它本质上是在娱乐你，给你一些好看的东西，而且很有趣、很享受，所以你几乎立刻就能得到满足。
But what this has done to our brains is seriously disrupt our systems for the distribution and release of dopamine. In the past, from an evolutionary standpoint, our brains were not used to receiving dopamine that quickly and that immediately and without such little effort. And now we become so used to getting that hit instantly that when things require consistency and when things are requiring long-term motivation and you may not receive that dopamine for some time, it becomes a lot harder for us to sustain the behaviors that will contribute to that. And long-term goals, any long-term goal that you have in mind, it will require delayed gratification. And what this refers to is the ability to delay an impulse for an immediate reward, such as going on your phone,
但这对我们的大脑所做的事情，是严重破坏了我们多巴胺的分发和释放系统。过去，从进化的角度来看，我们的大脑并不习惯如此迅速、如此直接且不费吹灰之力地接收多巴胺。现在我们已经习惯了立即获得这种冲击，以至于当事情需要坚持、需要长期动力并且你可能在一段时间内无法获得这种多巴胺时，我们要维持有助于达成目标的行为就变得困难得多了。而长期目标，你心中任何长期的目标，都需要延迟满足。这指的是推迟对即时奖励的冲动（例如玩手机）的能力，
to receive a more favorable reward later on. So if you're trying to finish an essay, you could go on your phone every five minutes and get a little dopamine hit. But what that's going to mean is that your essay is probably going to do. take a lot longer. And therefore, the kind of enjoyment you get from finishing it is going to not be as fun because it's going to have taken up more of your time and more of your effort. But if you delayed those immediate hits of dopamine from allowing yourself to be distracted or to go online, the gratification you're going to get when you complete the essay sooner, when it's better quality, is going to be much more profound. Psychologists discover this idea of
以便在稍后获得更有利的奖励。因此，如果你正试图完成一篇论文，你每隔五分钟就可以玩一次手机，并获得一点多巴胺冲击。但这将意味着你的论文可能需要做更长时间。因此，完成它所带来的那种快乐感将不会那么有趣，因为它占据了你更多的时间和精力。但是，如果你延迟了那些来自允许自己分心或上网的即时多巴胺冲击，当你更快地完成论文时，当论文质量更高时，你所获得的满足感将深远得多。心理学家发现了
delayed gratification in something known as the marshmallow experiment. So essentially in this experiment, they put participants in the room. The first round of this experiment was actually done with children. So they put these children in a room and in front of them they put a marshmallow. And they said to them, please do not eat this marshmallow. I'm going to leave the room. If you do not eat this marshmallow whilst I'm away, I'll give you two marshmallows. And then they would leave the room and they would see what the children would do.
延迟满足这一概念是通过一个被称为棉花糖实验的实验得出的。基本上在这个实验中，他们把参与者放在房间里。这个实验的第一轮实际上是和小朋友一起做的。所以他们把这些孩子放在一个房间里，在他们面前放了一个棉花糖。他们对孩子们说，请不要吃这个棉花糖。我要离开房间。如果我在离开的时候你没有吃掉这个棉花糖，我会给你两个棉花糖。然后他们会离开房间，观察孩子们会做什么。
And what they found was that a lot of the children would just eat the marshmallow. It didn't matter that if they waited and they held off on that immediate impulse, they would get two marshmallows, which is more favorable than one. They could not delay that gratification. And this experiment showed how delayed gratification grows over time and is often not fully developed in children, but it also has been adapted to show how us, this generation, humans nowadays, are also a lot worse at this experiment now.
他们发现许多孩子直接就把棉花糖吃了。如果他们等待并克制住那种即时的冲动，他们会得到两个棉花糖，这比一个棉花糖更好，但这并不重要。他们无法延迟这种满足感。这个实验表明了延迟满足感是如何随着时间增长的，并且在儿童中往往没有完全发育成熟，但它也被改编用来展示我们这一代人、现今的人类，在这个实验中也变得更差了。
A lot of us are really struggling to delay gratification. We want to eat the marshmallow. We don't want to wait for the bigger payoff. We want to feel that dopamine hit. We want to enjoy our rewards straight away. So the reality is, though, that we do need delayed gratification to sustain us. There are going to be times in your life where you're not going to get the outputs and you're not going to get the reward immediately. So we need to compromise and we need to find a way to sustain our behavior despite wanting that immediate dopamine hit.
我们许多人都在努力延迟满足。我们想吃棉花糖。我们不想等待更大的回报。我们想要感受多巴胺的冲击。我们想立刻享受我们的回报。然而现实是，我们确实需要延迟满足来支撑我们。在你的生活中总会有这样的时刻，你无法立即获得产出和回报。因此我们需要妥协，我们需要找到一种方法来维持我们的行为，尽管我们渴望那种即时的多巴胺冲击。
And that is the role of incremental gratification and setting up small, achievable, short-term goals that put us on the path towards long-term success. This is how you stay consistent. Instead of just giving yourself one goal, like I want to get an A on this course, you need to break it down into smaller incremental goals. For example, I want to get 80% on this quiz and I want to get an A plus on my literature review and I want to spend three hours a day revising my content before the exam. When you do these things, you tick off these small goals. that give you a sense of gratification and give you a sense of joy and happiness and allow your behavior to be sustained towards the big goal,
这就是循序渐进的满足感以及设定微小、可实现、短期目标的作用，这些目标将我们引向长期成功的道路。这就是你如何保持坚持。与其给自己定一个目标，比如我想在这门课上得A，你需要把它分解成更小的循序渐进的目标。例如，我想在这个小测验中得80%，我想在我的文学评论中得A加，我想在考试前每天花三个小时复习内容。当你做这些事情时，你勾选了这些小目标，
the end goal in sight being that great. We need to practice delayed gratification more often as well. And this can look something like waiting two minutes after you're thirsty before taking a sip of water or when you have an impulse to do something, practice delaying your fulfillment of that impulse. and this will translate to your ability to maintain daily consistency, to maintain your micro habits, and you'll see a big change by bringing in this idea of incremental gratification and delayed gratification into your daily life. My third tip is to not to get caught up in your failures.
这会给你一种满足感、喜悦感和幸福感，并使你的行为得以持续，朝着宏大的目标迈进，映入眼帘的最终目标就是那个优秀的分数。我们也需要更频繁地练习延迟满足。这可以表现为在你口渴两分钟后再喝一口水，或者当你有一种做某事的冲动时，练习推迟对这种冲动的满足。这将转化为你维持日常坚持、保持微习惯的能力，你会发现通过将这种循序渐进的满足感和延迟满足感的理念带入你的日常生活，会有巨大的改变。我的第三个建议是不要陷入失败中无法自拔。
That can be quite hard, but when we allow ourselves to only represent our self-worth based on what we haven't achieved and based on our perceived failures, that can really cause us to self-sabotage. And it jeopardizes our self-esteem, which is the foundation of all our behaviors and all of our consistent habits. If we only focus on the negatives, we kind of get lost in the weeds. And it really sabotages and derails our efforts to stay consistent. I think about it in this way. If one small setback is going to define our journey.
这可能相当困难，但当我们允许自己仅仅根据尚未实现的目标以及感知的失败来代表我们的自我价值时，这真的会导致我们自我破坏。它危及我们的自尊，而自尊是我们所有行为和所有坚持习惯的基础。如果我们只关注负面因素，我们就会在杂草丛生中迷失方向。这确实会破坏和阻碍我们保持坚持的努力。我是这样看待的。如果一个小挫折将决定我们的旅程。
journey, that journey is not going to last very long because everyone is going to experience setbacks. And if you fall over the first hurdle and don't get back up again, you're kind of never going to finish the race. So you need to switch your mindset to one that is pro failure. You have to remind yourself that there is no such thing as failure only lessons. Any long-term goal, like I said, is going to come with setbacks. And it's going to come with hard work and it's going to come with sacrifices. But if you only focus on the negative side of things, it's very easy to give up quite quickly. So I adopt this practice of celebrating my failures and I saw someone doing this the other day and it made me so proud and so happy. And essentially, what it does is it makes you feel that
那么这段旅程将不会持续很久，因为每个人都会经历挫折。如果你在第一个跨栏时摔倒了却没有重新站起来，你基本上就永远无法跑完这场比赛。所以你需要转变你的思维方式，转变为一种亲失败的心态。你必须提醒自己，世上没有失败，只有教训。正如我所说，任何长期目标都伴随着挫折。它伴随着努力工作和牺牲。但如果你只关注事情消极的一面，就很容易很快放弃。所以我采用了庆祝失败的做法，前几天我看到有人这样做，这让我感到非常自豪和高兴。本质上，这样做会让你觉得
your failures are just as important as your successes. So for example, if something doesn't go right instead of feeling ashamed by that instead of feeling this like sense of stigma and this sense of anxiety what you do is you celebrate the lesson that that contained maybe that involves having a glass of wine and saying oh my gosh look at me i got 60% on that quiz and you know what that means it means that i'm learned so much from what i did wrong there and i can adapt my i can adapt my studying habits, I can adapt my mindset and my outlook, and next time it's going to be even better. And I can avoid a greater pain later on during the semester, or it really does apply to everything. You need to celebrate your failures and treat them with the same amount of success
你的失败和你的成功同样重要。举个例子，如果事情进展不顺利，与其为此感到羞耻，与其感到这种耻辱感和焦虑感，不如去庆祝其中包含的教训。也许这包括喝一杯红酒并说：“天哪，看看我，我在那个测验中得了60%，你知道这意味着什么吗？这意味着我从我做错的地方学到了很多东西，我可以调整我的学习习惯，我可以调整我的心态和观点，下一次会更好。”我可以在学期晚些时候避免更大的痛苦，或者这真的适用于每件事。你需要庆祝你的失败，并以对待成功同等的成就感
and excitement as your successes, essentially. And what that does is it allows you to no longer get caught up in what is going wrong and caught up in what you're doing wrong, which will allow you to stop self-sabotaging your own journey. My next tip to building consistency seems counterintuitive, but it's rest. You need to rest. We can become so consumed by an ambition or a goal that we have in mind that we lose all semblance of balance. And all that is going to do is derail your ambitions and derail your success. You need a diversity of experiences and a diversity of stimulation to keep you sustained. If you want to be consistent towards a goal or an area in your life, you cannot purely be devoted to that goal because what's going to happen is you're going
和兴奋感来对待它们，本质上就是这样。这样做的好处是，它能让你不再纠结于什么地方出错了、你在哪里做错了，从而阻止你自我破坏自己的旅程。我培养坚持的下一个建议看起来有些违反直觉，但那就是休息。你需要休息。我们可能会被心中的雄心或目标消耗殆尽，以至于失去了平衡的任何迹象。而这只会破坏你的雄心和成功。你需要多样化的体验和多样化的刺激来维持动力。如果你想对一个目标或你生活中的某个领域保持坚持，你不能完全只投入于那个目标，因为将会发生的是
to hit a wall, you're going to become burnt out and you're going to quit. So what I always always recommend is kind of the 80-20 rule. And I've spoken about this before, but how it relates to building consistency is that 80% of your time should be devoted to the work. It should be devoted to your habits. But there is always got to be that 20% that is devoted to the things that make you happy beyond the context of striving towards your goals. What that allows for is your brain to receive stimulation and break up the day so that its motivation is sustained. So what that means is instead of spending all day in the library and then going home exhausted at 11 p.m., go and see a friend for dinner and break up your day, or go for a walk in the morning, or do something that you actually like to do
你会撞上南墙，你会精疲力竭然后放弃。所以我总是强烈推荐的是80-20法则。我之前谈到过这一点，但它与培养坚持的关系在于，你80%的时间应该投入到工作中。它应该投入到你的习惯中。但永远必须有那20%的时间留给那些在超越追求目标背景之外能让你快乐的事情。这允许你的大脑接受刺激并打断一整天，从而使你的动力得以持续。这意味着，与其一整天都待在图书馆然后在晚上11点筋疲力尽地回家，不如去和朋友吃晚饭来打破这一天的沉闷，或者在早上散步，或者做一些你真正喜欢做的事，
that's going to make it easier for you to return to the tasks at hand. And that really relates to anything. It relates to any goal. I know I'm using the academia example quite a bit. but I do think it's because it's so relevant in our 20s, but back to that one about drinking more water. If 80% of your day is focused on staying hydrated, let the other 20% be focused on having a nice can of Coke or a juice instead. You're allowed to give yourself rest days from your goals and they are just as important as those action-packed focused days as well. My final major tip is to create a reasonable routine. I am someone who has always struggled with routine. I find it really hard to stick to a certain schedule. I'm very much a go with the flow person.
这会让你更容易回到手头的工作中去。这确实适用于任何事情。它适用于任何目标。我知道我把学术的例子用得有点多。但我确实认为这是因为它在我们二十多岁时非常相关，不过回到多喝水那个例子上。如果你的白天的80%专注于保持水分，那么剩下的20%可以专注于喝一罐不错的可口可乐或果汁。你可以允许自己从目标中获得休息日，它们和那些充满行动、高度集中的日子一样重要。我最后的重大建议是建立一个合理的常规。我一直是个在常规方面苦苦挣扎的人。我发现自己很难坚持某个固定的时间表。我非常随性。
But one of my friends said it this way and I think that it's really valuable how she presented it to me. And that is to start, instead of jumping straight into a daily routine, start with a monthly routine. What are the things that you want to get done on a monthly basis and when do you need them to be scheduled in throughout the month? Once you have accomplished that, then you move to a week by week basis. So say, for example, on a weekly basis, you want to work out three times a week in order to achieve some kind of health or fitness goal you have. You can schedule those in the week where best suits you and try your best to follow that. And why? And why? And why? You can schedule those in the week. And Once you feel that you have a good handle over your monthly schedule and then your weekly schedule,
但我的一个朋友是这样说的，我认为她向我阐述的方式非常有价值。那就是，不要直接一头扎进日常常规，而是从月度常规开始。你希望在每个月完成哪些事情，以及你需要在全月的什么时间安排它们？一旦你完成了这一点，就转向按周进行的计划。所以比方说，按周来看，你希望一周锻炼三次，以实现某种健康或健身目标。你可以在一周中最适合的时候把它们安排进去，并尽最大努力去遵循。为什么呢？为什么呢？为什么呢？你可以在一周内安排这些。一旦你觉得你对每月的日程安排有了很好的掌控，接着是每周的日程安排，
move on to your daily schedule. It's about starting small, as we were talking about with the micro habits. The worst, well, I guess the easiest way to derail any goal that you have is to go all in too quickly and to exhaust yourself and completely change your life. That's going to feel really unnatural. our brains and our minds and our bodies like comfort. They like what is known. They do not like novel new experiences that kind of shake our core and our sense of
就可以转到你的日常日程安排。这就像我们在微习惯中讨论的那样，从A小处着手。毁掉你任何目标的最好方法，或者说最简单的方法，就是太快地全力以赴、精疲力竭并彻底改变你的生活。那会感觉很不自然。我们的大脑、思维和身体喜欢舒适。它们喜欢熟悉的事物。它们不喜欢那种动摇我们核心以及我们的
kind of convenience and comfort. So if you immediately have the school in mind and you change everything about your life, it's not going to be sustainable. So starting small and building up to the big is an incredible way to ensure that you are consistent with regards to your goals. Also set reminders for yourself as well. If you've got something in mind that you want to achieve, one of the best ways to keep your brain engaged in that long-term goal
便利感和舒适感的新颖体验。因此，如果你脑海中立刻有了这个目标并改变了你生活的方方面面，那是无法持续的。所以从小处着手，逐步积聚成大事，是确保你在目标上保持坚持的绝佳方法。同时也要为自己设置提醒。如果你心中有想要实现的目标，保持大脑持续投入于那个长期目标
and to stay consistent in the habits that are required for its success is to remind yourself as often as possible your reasons for being invested in this and your vision. When I was at school, actually, one of my teachers told me to print out pictures of my dream university and the literal numbers of the grades that I wanted and place them around my desk. And I thought that was a little bit insane. I was like, that is, I do not want to be consumed by this goal. But what it actually did was allow me to stay more motivated because I had a visual cue and a visual reminder as to why I was pursuing a certain set of habits and a certain goal. And so on those days when it was harder to really get
以及保持成功所需习惯的坚持的方法之一，就是尽可能经常地提醒自己你投资于此的原因以及你的愿景。我在学校的时候，其实我的一位老师告诉我，把我的梦想大学的照片和我想取得的成绩的字面数字打印出来，贴在我的书桌周围。我觉得这有点疯狂。我想的是，这太……我不想被这个目标消耗。但它实际上所做的是让我保持更高的动力，因为我有了视觉线索和视觉提醒，提醒我为什么要追求某一套习惯和某一个目标。所以在那些更难真正
out of bed and it was harder to not give in to that instant gratification and go on my phone, that visual reminder acted as a safety net for my lack of motivation and it was incredibly powerful. I also think that it's important to surround yourself with people who have similar goals and that will inspire you. This was advice that was given to me by the wonderful Violet Benson. She hosts the podcast Almost Adalting. And she told me that the easiest way for us to fall off the bandwagon and to give up on our goals is to be surrounded by people who don't believe in them and to be surrounded by people who don't believe enough in their own goals.
起床的日子里，在那些更难克制即时满足不去玩手机的日子里，那个视觉提醒就像是我动力不足的安全网，而且它极其强大。我还认为，结交那些有类似目标且会激励你的人非常重要。这个建议是由精彩的维奥莱特·本森给我的。她主持了播客《几乎成年》（Almost Adulting）。她告诉我，让我们误入歧途、放弃目标的捷径，就是身边围绕着不相信这些目标的人，以及身边围绕着对自己的目标都不够相信的人。
That is one of the worst things you can do because we have to remind ourselves that we are an amalgamation of our five closest people in our lives, our five closest friends. our five closest friends, our family members, our partners, those people are what makes up our identity and from our identity stems our motivation. So it may seem harsh, but if you are around people who are going to pressure you into sacrificing your work to go and have fun all the time or are going to pressure you into feeling like your goals and your ambitions aren't worthy or don't deserve or don't deserve your time, I guess, you're kind of not really setting yourself up for a great start there. You're not really setting yourself up for success. So really closely examine
那是你能做的最糟糕的事情之一，因为我们必须提醒自己，我们是我们生活中最亲密的五个人、我们最亲密的五个朋友的结合体。我们最亲密的五个朋友、我们的家庭成员、我们的伴侣，这些人构成了我们的身份，而从我们的身份中衍生出了我们的动力。所以这听起来可能很严厉，但如果你身边的人总是向你施压，让你为了去玩乐而牺牲工作，或者向你施压，让你觉得你的目标和雄心不值得或不配得到你的时间，我想，你其实并没有为自己开个好头。你真的没有为成功做好准备。所以要非常仔细地审视
where you sit and where your goals sit in regards to your environment, including your relationships. And it doesn't mean entirely cutting people out. That's ridiculous. But I think what it does mean is knowing what it's going to come at an expense of. And it doesn't mean. And and reminding yourself perhaps more often why you can't go out and drink and why it's probably not great to spend every night clubbing or every night hanging out with these people because you have a bigger goal in mind and you want to stay consistent. I've spent a large portion of this episode really rattling on about consistency and motivation and I think maybe we need a breath of fresh air from that because this is your daily reminder
你所处的位置以及你的目标在你的环境（包括人际关系）中所处的位置。这并不意味着完全把人切断。那太荒谬了。但我认为这意味着要清楚这会带来什么代价。而且这并不意味着。而且……也许应该更经常地提醒自己为什么你不能出去喝酒，为什么每天晚上泡吧或和这些人鬼混可能不是什么好主意，因为你有一个更大的目标，而且你想保持坚持。我在这一集的很大一部分时间里都在喋喋不休地谈论坚持和动力，我想也许我们需要呼吸一下新鲜空气，因为这是你的日常提醒，
that not everything is about being productive. Our society is very success-focused and success-oriented. And I think that that can be dangerous because it convinces us that our outputs and our successes are the sole source of our worth. And that's not true. We can't forget that we are more than our achievements. We are more than our consistency.
并不是所有事情都与高产有关。我们的社会非常注重成功和以成功为导向。我认为这可能是危险的，因为它说服我们，我们的产出和成功是我们价值的唯一来源。事实并非如此。我们不能忘记，我们的价值远不止我们的成就。我们远不止我们的坚持。
We are more than our habits. It's very easy, I think, especially in our 20s, when we're really consumed by this pressure to be successful and to achieve all these amazing goals and amazing milestones, it can be very easy to think that the only value that we have to society is what we put out and that our success is the only thing that matters. And that's not true. You need to see that your identity and you need to recognize that your identity is more than just that.
我们远不止我们的习惯。我认为这很容易发生，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，当我们真正被这种成功的压力所吞噬，想要实现所有这些惊人的目标和惊人的里程碑时，很容易认为我们对社会的唯一价值就是我们的产出，而我们的成功是唯一重要的事情。事实并非如此。你需要看到你的身份，你需要认识到你的身份不仅仅是那样。
It's actually made up of five core buckets. It's made up of your relationships, of your hobbies. It's made up of your values, your characteristics, and then your achievements. And as someone who gets very hyper-fixated on one goal and can find that everything else around me kind of gets blocked out by this hyper-fixated. taxation. Sometimes it's really important to deliberately remind yourself that life is more than that. Life is more than your grades. Life is more than your career success. It's more than some fitness goal you have. It's also about enjoying your life and pouring as much as you can into every single domain so that you are happy. But back to what we were speaking about today, let's quickly summarize those tips.
它实际上由五个核心部分组成。它由你的人际关系、你的爱好组成。它由你的价值观、你的性格特征，然后是你的成就组成。作为一个人，我有时会对一个目标过度执着，并发现我周围的其他一切都被这种过度执着所屏蔽。有时，刻意提醒自己生活不只是那样，真的很重要。生活不仅仅是你的成绩。生活不仅仅是你的职业成功。它不仅仅是你的某种健身目标。它还关乎享受生活，并在每一个领域倾注你尽可能多的精力，以便你感到快乐。但回到我们今天讨论的话题，让我们快速总结一下这些建议。
all of us want to be consistent. And I do think, like I said at the beginning, consistency is the easiest way to sustain our motivation and to stay focused on our long-term goals, but also enable us to enjoy life. So in order to build consistency, we need to focus on our micro-habits, the small everyday things you can change in your life. We need to set both long-term and short-term goals, including focusing on delayed gratification and incremental gratification. We also need to rest. We need to not focus on our small setbacks and our small failures. They are not what matters.
我们所有人都想保持坚持。而且我认为，正如我在开始时所说的那样，坚持是维持我们动力、保持对长期目标专注的最简单方法，同时也能让我们享受生活。因此，为了建立坚持，我们需要关注我们的微习惯，即你可以改变生活中的微小日常事物。我们需要设定长期和短期目标，包括专注于延迟满足和循序渐进的满足感。我们还需要休息。我们需要不把注意力放在我们的小挫折和小失败上。那些根本不重要。
And we need to create a reasonable routine, something that is actually very easy to integrate, rather than going all or nothing straight away, because that is the easiest path to burnout and to kind of falling off the bandwagon. So I hope that you have enjoyed this. I hope that this has motivated you towards your goals. We are such an ambitious generation, I think, and a lot of us have these grand ideas in mind. And like I've said, so many times throughout this episode, you're not going to get there without consistency.
我们需要建立一个合理的常规，一个很容易融入生活的常规，而不是直接采取非此即彼的做法，因为那是通往精疲力竭和半途而废的最简单途径。所以我希望你们喜欢这一期节目。我希望这能激励你们朝着自己的目标前进。我认为我们是一个非常有雄心的群体，我们很多人脑海里都有这些宏伟的想法。就像我在这集节目中多次说过的那样，没有坚持，你是不可能成功的。
The secret to success is consistency. And that is what's going to sustain you even when your motivation fails you. So I hope this has given you some practical, tangible advice and habits that you can implement in your own life. I'm rooting for you. I know you're going to get it done. I know you're going to achieve everything that you want. So hopefully with some of this information and some of this psychology, you can make some of
成功的秘诀就是坚持。即使在动力不足的时候，这也是支撑你坚持下去的动力。所以我希望这能为你提供一些切实的建议和习惯，你可以将它们应用到你自己的生活中。我支持你。我知道你能做到。我知道你会实现你想要的一切。希望凭借这些信息和心理学知识，你能将其中一些
those dreams a reality. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Now, if you have a friend in mind who needs to hear this episode, send them the link right now. You should send it to them. It might help them out. It might make their day. And if you have an episode suggestion, like I always say, please feel free to follow us at
梦想变成现实。和往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你脑海中有一个朋友需要听听这期节目，现在就把链接发给他。你应该发给他。这可能会帮到他，可能会让他的生活充满阳光。如果你有节目建议，就像我经常说的，请随时关注我们的
that psychology podcast. I love hearing from you. I love hearing what's going on in your life and how psychology and science can explain some of those experiences. So please feel free to share over there and give us some feedback. just come and say hi, whatever suits you best. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
that psychology podcast。我喜欢听你们分享。我喜欢听听你们生活中的近况，以及心理学和科学如何解释这些经历。所以请随时在那里分享并给我们一些反馈。来打个招呼也行，怎么方便怎么来。我们下周将推出另一期节目。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier, person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWO%。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在 Look Back at it 播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。1984年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听的是由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间关于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。